all right you are going to get some fans
there you go crank it up
put it on setting 2 if you have to
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today i'm joined by comedian wanda sykes
she's an emmy award winner with over two
decades in the stand up game you know
her from tv shows like blackish and curb
your enthusiasm you can catch your
latest project face value wednesdays on
bt 10 9 central wanda welcome to the
show thank you thanks for having me here
how are you with hot food i enjoy hot
food but i like to enjoy it it's not a
challenge for me you're sort of hacking
the game already you have the powered
fan ready to go you're in a good
position right now in great position yes
i feel good about this
[Music]
[Applause]
i like how you mix up the little uh
you know the flat pieces the flaps and
then
the
a little smoke tour
okay
so i want to start by taking it back to
your career before show business because
i know that you worked for the federal
government the nsa what do you remember
about wanda sykes the government
operative a lot of the people who were
like getting close to retirement they
all had side jobs like somebody like
selling candles or
uh you know fruit
i knew early on that that's not where i
wanted to be for a long time wikileaks
do you think it's making the world a
better place worse place they're picking
and choosing what they want to release
yeah okay if it's something that we find
entertaining and it takes down someone
that we don't like then yay good for you
know we're happy but then what uh who
are they protected you know it's like i
don't like that they pick and choose
who to go after
[Music]
is this a race or something damn
how fast you're eating that wing you're
eating it faster than me you've already
cleared it i still have some meat on the
bone don't come after me like that
[Music]
so despite your many successful projects
and storied stand-up career i have to
imagine that it's curb your enthusiasm
fans that are some of the biggest monda
obsessives what sort of pitch did you
get was like it's like wanda sykes but
you yell more you know like do you
remember what it was like
um
i was friends with one of the producers
on the show
she called and she's like we're shooting
at this car dealership come down here
and meet larry okay i'd say well i'm not
auditioning she's like no no you're just
going to meet him because one i hate
auditioning i suck at it i probably
would never get a job if i had to
audition
so i get down there and there's like
six other black women sitting at this
car dealership and they're like wait a
second i'm like what the come on
i'm in my audition and then she go hey
you're here come on in and she just
pushed me in the room and there's larry
and jeff and larry's like you're out for
a walk and i drive by and i go hey i
know that tush anywhere i don't know why
the [ __ ] would you say something like
that he just fell out laughing he just
thought it was the funniest thing and we
just went back and forth and he was like
okay yeah you you have the job he kind
of tricked you into a curb your
enthusiasm scene right you know like you
kind of fell into his trap yeah it
worked out pretty well yeah i'm
surprised he didn't ask me to come back
let's see how that goes
what the hell portland knows about hot
sauce
his secret aardvark what the hell
um
is the crazy eyes killa episode the best
ever in your opinion do you have one
that's a favorite everyone loves that
episode that's uh not one of my
favorites it makes me so [ __ ] nervous
it really does because whenever a white
person comes up to me and says oh man
crazy eye killer and i'm like this don't
say it don't say it
oh jesus is he gonna say it please don't
say it and i'm just waiting for him to
say you know are you my i'm like uh
don't come on man don't say it i don't
want to fight you in this airport
scotch bonnet and ginger sauce
a little hair on it right there okay
you leave the hair on that's the youtube
red carpet treatment wanda welcome to my
world
all right so on your new show face value
contestants are rewarded on their
ability to profile total strangers so
now i'm gonna turn the tables on you
wando what i've done is i've pulled up
some pictures of people who work behind
the scenes here at hot ones what i'm
hoping you can do is identify their role
here okay maybe a character trait or two
and maybe their most annoying habit i'll
keep this just from a picture just from
a picture oh wow straight from a picture
wanda okay not a lot to work off of okay
it's okay i can do this you can do it
yeah
here we have
chris murphy doing chris murphy things
chris murphy still lives at home
he goes it takes the lunch orders and uh
and he and he [ __ ] it up a lot too
i can tell
and he's always trying to like hang out
after work
and you guys are all like nah man we're
going home and i got this thing i got to
do
so he's like okay and then you guys get
together without him you drew back the
arrow and just
bullseye bullseye
kristen
slaying on how vote in portugal that's a
powerful black woman right there yeah
she is she's not taking any lip
she will put you in your place
uh
she's probably the receptionist
that's the gatekeeper right there
here we have chris schoenberger oh boy
this guy's sad
might be gay
his dog ruggles over here and his dog is
like don't jump buddy
you got me that's what the dog is saying
this is um
so it seems like comedians who love
their craft they yearn for nothing more
than the microphone as somebody who is a
political satirist and somebody who
focuses on political humor have you
noticed a difference in the way that
these rooms are received in different
cities throughout the country i mean i
would hope and what i've whatever what
i've experienced if you come to see
wanda sykes you should know what you're
what you're
coming for which what you're gonna get
now every now and then you get a few
people who like oh let's go see barb
from the new adventures of old christine
and they get in there and then they're
like what the hell is this what you know
what is she talking about she's gay what
the [ __ ] you know and they're
cursing and screaming they run out with
their hair on fire
so this one's dirty dicks very
aggressive brand name
dirty dicks
all right
i like them okay a nice little sweetness
to it oh let's pick up with the tropical
twist that's what it is so i recently
heard you cracking jokes about jay-z's
ashy penis which i think may be your
most haunting phrase to date i have all
the things i've said that that one just
landed that one it was a bomb that went
off in my brain
are you beehive
till you die are you a little suspicious
of the new beyonce get the sense that
you're a fan in limbo
i am i am all in i'm 100 beyonce i'm
beehive yes i am that the the last album
the lemonade that that won't be back
would you let your kids watch the
drunken love video hell no
why would i do that
no
okay
okay hello
hello
mm-hmm
[Music]
because you couldn't like do a little
gradual and quick i mean this is uh
this is kind of like a hot i don't i'm
not enjoying that's the road i think
we're gonna take to the finish line oh
really yeah
oh
all right you are going to get some fans
there you go crank it up
put it on setting too if you have to
freaking my tongue there just oh okay
i'm still eating it okay is it
so in 2009 he did a white house
correspondence dinner which is an event
that i always find fascinating
especially from a comedian's perspective
do you have to get jokes approved you
have to jump through different hurdles
how is it different i was shocked too
that i thought i would have to
send in all my jokes and they tell me
what i could say couldn't say nothing
i kept asking uh do they want a
recording or do they want the script
nothing
is there anything that bricked that you
thought would play well and it just kind
of fell flat i think it's because the
first lady put a bus of sojourner truth
in the white house i told her i said
look when you guys leave make sure you
you nailed it down you know
but because uh you know the next white
people who get in the
who who are there they're gonna move her
to the kitchen
so
[Laughter]
and then that one was a little flat
that one was a little flat
didn't care for that one
so far
no big oh there it is
oh boy
okay
shit's getting real
yeah
is there a piece of parenting advice
that everyone thinks is really good
advice but that you've decided is not
particularly good advice
the spanking thing
uh yeah we we didn't spank but
well i i did i did spank them a couple
times
i got a couple of pep peps off
oh
i got you wanda
thanks sir how do you tell your kids
that they suck at something how do you
let them down easy
i do a big loud boom just boom
[Music]
actually we i mean that's the thing it's
thumbs up thumbs down that's what we do
that's what we do everybody always wants
to feed all the oh you're so great
you're so this you're so that no like
sometimes you just need to give it to
them real
[Music]
my kids do it to me too thumbs up thumbs
down
[Music]
how you feeling
i'm
you don't want to know how i'm feeling
right now
oh boy
i think i'm camping out you gotta tap
i'm just chilling just chill just jump
line up
[Music]
yeah i'm i'm 53. yeah
i can't eat this crap anymore right
right my stomach is like oh boy
it's it's kind of going a little bit
crazy over there
this but this is the problem it's it
goes like from one to these are like
threes
and then you go to
18.
right
and then this
is like a hundred right right because
now mm-hmm
i could say anything
it's you know i'm ready to you know
confess the [ __ ] i haven't even done
that's that's where my mind is right now
i
yeah i did
i [ __ ] kevin hart yeah it was me
what
and this is actually this is indeed
hotter than or they're all on this thing
here's what i would say to you
[Music]
guests always have the hardest time with
this one okay if you can get on top of
this one you can get on top of this one
you can get on top of this one i would
say this wanda don't try to be a hero
you know what i mean don't go there
you've been cleaning wings all the way
through i think you were lulled into a
little bit of i was a sense of false
security you know
louie on crystal you were like there's
not enough on there's not enough there's
not enough and now we're at a point
where you're just sort of hitting a wall
hard
this is not a peer pressure situation
okay i'm gonna take a bite and ask a
question
if you want to go swimming you can go
swimming if you want to tap you can tap
it's not the end of the world
[Music]
wow
be careful
can i call my mother
[Music]
so your wife is french and i imagine
that you have a lifestyle that's a
little more continental than it used to
be france i feel like is romanticized by
everyone but as we know wanda is not
always so easily impressed so what i'm
going to do is bounce some french things
off of you and you can tell me if
they're overrated or underrated does
that sound like i'm on top of that okay
escargot
underrated i say underweight even if you
don't eat the escargot it's that bread
in the
it's a good dip
yes don't don't sleep on the dip french
wine it's better
it doesn't hit you in the face with you
know alcohol but i mean their their
vines are older it's older so it's yeah
a little more complex
joe will freeze
i love him i love him my feast uh annoys
me oh yeah yeah because because he he
it's it's like this he he sucks you in
and you're like oh i think my thesis is
going to put it together he's going to
do it and then he realized he made it
then he does something dumb you know
jumping up in the air hitting it between
his legs like man come on just get the
ball back over the net
just focus on that french sense of humor
oh
overrated they're they're awful
oh boy
my brain is like melting right now
is that normal it's it is like my mind
is just
gone
all right wanda
what are you doing
so this is the last extra day up that's
right its reputation has preceded it i
see wanda all right so it's tradition
around here
to put
a little extra on the last wing you
don't have to if you don't want to wanda
i know you're going through it a little
bit you don't have to
there it is there it is you know
that's good
i'm here for the sport for the
respect yeah respect
all right
is that a little little publicist stare
down we've had many of those on how once
[Music]
i mean i mean yeah listen listen you
know you know where it's going you know
where it's going you don't have to go
there you don't have to go there monday
you don't have to
i'm going there all right all right
all right
this listen
send me to the er
all right wanda you started your career
alongside dave chappelle and chris rock
and emmy countless tv shows movies and
comedy specials later somehow you ended
up in front of me eating the wings of
death on hot ones yes so if this is your
undoing if the last dab is in fact the
last chapter i wonder which comedian
would you want to deliver the eulogy at
your funeral and why
keith robinson
he knows me
best i know he'll make it funny
he'll give me a nice send-off
if today or tonight
you're walking home
a large black man jumps out of an alley
and kicks your ass
i had nothing to do with
all right that sounds like an open
invite to me and look at you wanda sykes
you made it through i know that it was a
little bit of a trying moment here at
the bomb but you fired up the you fired
up the fan you got another one out going
in for a second bite one sykes what a
legend now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you
wanda thank you this camera this camera
or this camera let the people know what
you have going on in your life we um
have a show
uh premiering september 27th b-e-t
called face value hosted by dion cole
and tiffany haddish we talk show the
game show on true tv we got picked up
for the second season that'll be back
with guy branham i'm on blackish
[Music]
thank you
you really like like lose your mind
yeah
it's crazy right i couldn't put it
together i was like
good lord hello world sean evans coming
at you to say thank you for watching if
you like what you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the 000th ranked
youtube channel in the world it has been
a childhood dream of mine to be
somewhere in the mid twos we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please jk jk no
pressure but if you do subscribe i
appreciate it